new concerns about a potential russian
invasion of ukraine new satellite images
show that russian troops in belarus have
moved closer to ukraine's border in fact
they are now just about 30 miles away
meanwhile dozens of elite american
airborne troops have arrived in poland
to protect that country and the u.s says
that russia could invade ukraine any day
but moscow does insist it has no plans
to do so mts taeyab is in the ukrainian
capital for cmts i imagine tensions are
running high good morning
indeed tony good morning well those
intelligence reports which warned of
mass casualties and the displacement of
millions have set alarm bells ringing
across europe as ukraine remains caught
in the middle
real guns
real bullets for a possible war with a
very real adversary this group of
civilians are being trained to use
automatic weapons
whether russia invades or not
anyone's guess but those who come here
for training are preparing for the worse
instructing these urban fighters in the
making
are military veterans who've spent years
fighting pro-russian separatists in
ukraine's east
including this sergeant who goes by the
name alex
it must be terrifying though to have so
many russian forces so much russian
weaponry right on your doorstep
not too terrifying for us because we
fight already eight years you know or
every day from 2014.
u.s intelligence officials warned that a
russian invasion could kill up to one
hundred thousand civilians
but many ukrainians still remain
unconvinced vladimir putin will attack
on newscasts across ukraine there's
barely a mention of the tensions instead
the top stories are a supermarket
scandal and ukraine's fashion week
pablo klimklin is a former ukrainian
foreign minister i don't believe
in big invasion right now
it's actually not in the interest of
putin what putin needs now
is to raise the stakes to reach that
pressure
now that pressure has led to a flurry of
international diplomacy you have the
french president meeting with vladimir
putin in moscow today and germany's
chancellor sitting down with president
biden at the white house as world
leaders try to end this conflict without
bloodshed gail
all right mts taya from ukraine thank
you very much